oh ah oh God I just inhaled that it's a
different type of burd ow he's not
trying to cook for us he's trying to
kill
us hey guys it's Chef Esther Choy and
we're back season two of heat eaters
last season reignited my love of spicy
food that's hot you guys have water but
this season we're cranking the heat up a
notch kind of like in spinal tap your
speaker goes to 11 it's pleasure pain
join me and some friends do love me I
mhm
mhm as we Brave another fiery culinary
Quest I don't know if you know about the
last stab the spiciest of them
all why did you do that venturing on a
food craw of New York City's most iconic
spicy foods that's wildly good it's a
different like level of spice indulging
in a South Asian Feast to explode your
senses the Naga chili is something that
you'll see in Bangladeshi cuisine on the
Scoville scale I think it's like over a
million yeah transforming instant
noodles into a spice Laden extravaganza
the heat eater spicy noodles of Joshua
Weissman and master Choy you're welcome
to Hell seeking out the ultimate spicy
chicken sandwich juicy chicken sounds
sexy and visiting the hottest pepper
Farm in the
world oh my
God can you handle the heat again oh I
got the sweats oh God oh God no that's
really hot I GL how spicy it was oh
this is heat eaters is he really going
to throw up yes you just had him eat
half of a pepper that's hotter than the
Carolina reap sorry Bill sorry
[Music]
Bill